>> Jon: HOW COULD
OBAMA NOT BE THERE?
LOOK HOW MANY WORLD LEADERS
HE COULD HAVE BOWED DOWN TO
AND APOLOGIZED.
HE COULD HAVE -- HE MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY.
HOW COULD THE U.S. NOT BE THERE?
WHEN REPRESENTATIVES OF SUCH
BEACONS OF FREEDOM AND LACK
OF CENSORSHIP AS
JOURNALIST-PUNISHING RUSSIA
WAS THERE JOURNALIST-JAILING
TURKEY WAS THERE.
EGYPT, ENOUGH SAID.
PALESTINIAN CARTOONIST-JAILING
ISRAEL WAS THERE AND OF
COURSE, OUR GREATEST ALLY,
SAUDI ARABIA WAS THERE
ALTHOUGH A LITTLE OUT OF
BREATH HAVING JUST DAYS AGO
FLOGGED A BLOGGER.
COULDN'T OBAMA HAVE AT LEAST
SENT A FRIEND?
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
HOLDER WAS IN PARIS.
>> Jon: OKAY, ALL RIGHT,
THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT, I'M SORRY.
I JUMPED TO CONCLUSIONS.
ERIC HOLDER, THE TOP LAW
OFFICIAL IN THE UNITED
STATES, OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL,
I MEAN COME ON, FRANCE,
HOLDER'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH YOU?
YOU ARE ONLY HAPPY WITH THE
GRANDE FROMAGE.
>> ALTHOUGH ATTORNEY GENERAL
ERIC HOLDER WAS IN PARIS FOR
COUNTERTERRORISM MEETINGS,
HE DID NOT ATTEND THE MARCH.
>> WHAT THE [BLEEP]?
ERIC HOLDER, YOU
WERE IN FRANCE, IN PARIS AT
THE TIME OF THE MARCH AND
WERE LIKE --
(LAUGHTER)
OH, I GET IT YOU WERE
PROBABLY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE SHORTEST TOURIST LINES
IN FRENCH HISTORY.
WHILE THE MARCH IS GOING ON
YOU'RE JUST KICKING BACK
SNAPPING SELFIES WITH THE MONA
LISA, STEALING CATACOMB BONES,
FINALLY GETTING A TABLE AT
FRANCE'S MOST POPULAR
RAT-OWNED BISTRO.
IS THAT WHAT YOU WERE DOING?
UNBELIEVABLE.
AN ENORMOUS GLOBAL RALLY IN
SUPPORTING FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION AFTER ATTACK ON A
CLOSE ALLY AND THE U.S. WAS
A NO-SHOW?
IT IS GOING TO TAKE A LOT TO
MAKE UP FOR THIS.
>> JOHN KERRY SAID THIS
MORNING HE WILL GO TO
FRANCE LATER THIS WEEK.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: JE SUIS TO BE KIDDING ME.